a little bit later i'm going to be doing
a deeper sort of more detailed dive into
yesterday's very very unusual press
briefing that donald trump gave but i
want to focus
in specifically on something for a
moment where donald trump actually said
something that is
completely correct sort of but he said
it
for completely self-centered and greedy
reasons and unfortunately some on the
left have kind of fallen for it and it's
really disturbing to see so let me kind
of set this all up for you
donald trump sort of nailed and exposed
the military industrial complex at its
core
during yesterday's press briefing i'm
going to play the clip for you
the only problem is that he seems to
have no awareness of the fact that
he has contributed to growing to feeding
that same military-industrial complex
that he criticized yesterday and of
course the reason that donald trump said
this
was to try to make himself look better
that's always donald trump's priority so
let's go in steps as we should
here is donald trump explaining why
some of the top people at the pentagon
as he claims
do not like him in reference to the
story
about donald trump allegedly saying
troops who died in combat
are losers and suckers here is donald
trump biden
shipped away our jobs threw open our
borders and sent our youth to fight in
these
crazy endless wars and it's one of the
reasons the military i'm not saying the
military is in love with me the soldiers
are
the top people in the pentagon probably
aren't because they want to
do nothing but fight wars so that all of
those wonderful companies that make the
bombs and make the planes and make
everything else stay happy
but uh so this actually
is a critique that makes a lot of sense
donald trump points out that part of how
the pentagon operates
and part of how the military operates is
impossible to extricate it's impossible
to separate from defense
and military contractors i don't
remember a republican president
and even many democratic presidents so
clearly
calling this out good for trump he said
something that is
mostly correct now there's a couple of
problems with this
the main problem of course is that
everything donald trump has done
has actually fed the military-industrial
complex you might think well hey trump's
right he didn't get us into any wars as
he defines them he's not the war
president
but he's certainly done some bombing but
put the bombing aside for a second
donald trump has bragged his entire
presidency about all of the arms deals
and purchases that he has made he's
bragged about how much he sold
to saudi arabia and the deal he brokered
for american military contractors to
saudi arabia
the entire term that he has come up with
of refilling the cupboards
he claims the cupboards were left empty
by barack obama he's talking about
military equipment he regularly brags
about having rebuilt the military bigger
and better and more powerful than ever
before that is trump
feeding the military-industrial complex
that he sounded like he was criticizing
there
so this was sort of like a rare moment
of clarity for trump in some sense
but it's for completely greedy personal
reasons
that he stumbled across something that's
sort of true
and he's part of the problem the reason
that donald trump said this
is not to actually critique the military
military-industrial complex in fact
everything he's done has supported it
trump was trying to explain away why
somebody at the military or the pentagon
might say something negative about him
that is all that he cares about and
very sadly some on the left have fallen
for it
uh i i my instinct is that it's the sort
of tulsi gabbard
crowd they have fallen for this and they
are now saying trump is well to the left
of anybody you know
left of obama left abide no trump isn't
actually calling out the
military-industrial complex trump has
bragged for four years
about feeding and fueling the
military-industrial complex and then my
my last thought on this the
military-industrial complex
isn't even really generals who want to
start
wars and they're mad at trump because
they won't let him he won't let them
start a war
that's not really the way it happens the
way that the military-industrial complex
stuff happens the revolving door of
money
is lobbyists pushing congress for pork
and congress doing it because they want
donations
and all of these other projects for
their districts that's
really the military-industrial complex
so yes trump
is right to some degree but the idea
that that's how it works
ignoring the whole lobbying industrial
complex
really misses a big piece of it so okay
you know let's let's praise trump to the
degree that he deserves praise
but let's understand that he is
a huge part of the problem and is only
saying this because he's trying to
explain away the atlantic story which
has of course since been corroborated
by the associated press and by fox news
and by cnn we actually do i don't
believe that this is
being overly cynical i believe it's
being realistically skeptical tell me if
you think i'm wrong
let's now look at some other outrageous
moments from yesterday's press briefing
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
when you go to davidpakman.com watch
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches from
top
quality materials and they just look
great i went on their site and picked
out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 off everything in their
store when you go to davidpakman.com
watch and i've put that link right
underneath this video